alright I go on vacation for one week
one week and now decides to drop the
biggest csgo update in years the Galil
and the FAMAS have been buffed the Krieg
has been nerfed we got new maps new
skins new stickers a new operation the
first one in like 910 days apparently
and yes new customizable player models
it's all so beautiful there's just one
teensy little problem those customizable
player models have been wreaking havoc
in competitive modes and some major TOS
have already banned them alright guys
apologies for not getting to this
massive csgo
update earlier but as I said I was
literally on vacation in Disney World in
fact shout-out to you guys who found me
in Disney World and decided to stop by
and say hi anyways by the time I came
back the shattered web update was in
full effect and csgo went from the
world's premiere fps to a predator
simulator
[Music]
yes obviously I'm talking about the
customizable player bottles and hey they
look great I am very very happy to have
them in the game from an aesthetic
perspective but the problem is pretty
obvious put a certain custom skin
character against a certain background
and it makes them extremely difficult to
see this Cape to fix it
just to be clear here this feature has
the potential of fundamentally changing
how csgo is played if you know that a
certain skin is gonna be almost
impossible to see in certain places
you're going to play differently when
equipping that skin all of a sudden you
might be positioning yourself in some
weirdest [ __ ] corner that you would
never play before all because the SEAL
Team six soldier guy blends into the
flower pots under balcony okay clear
great cool a little bit later look guys
I am 31 years old okay my eyesight is
not nearly as sharp as some of these
cracked of kids out there I mean I have
trouble seeing a team model playing
plaqued
at V site on dust2 so this gonna be a
problem for me now aside from the color
of the new player models their actual
build is different as well their hitbox
is apparently the same but this means if
you choose a particular model you might
stick out from a corner that previously
you wouldn't stick out from if you pick
that steampunk looking ass guy maybe
your co-op sticks out when you're
crouching and you get headshot of
because of it could happen so you can
see how these new models really do
represent a potentially significant
change in how a map of csgo can be
played and obviously tournament
organizers out there have also taken
notice as of the recording of this video
ESEA ESL and ECS have all banned the
custom player models and that's all well
and good for a lot of people but some of
us slobs still play matchmaking and for
us counter-strike could become a bit of
a different game
again where even the most methodical
corner checking player can get caught
off-guard by some weirdo posted up
against a wall that you can't discern
from his character model I hate your
face did you say something you're
[ __ ] weird
now valve has already pushed some
lighting updates to some of the maps and
that will alleviate some of the problems
we're talking about but it's by no means
a permanent solution war camo spots are
bound to be discovered and simply
constantly tweaking the lighting on
every single map all the time doesn't
seem like a viable or sustainable
solution for valve so other than banning
all these custom character models in
every single competitive load which
would defeat the purpose of them in the
first place what can be done well the
solution for competitive seems pretty
simple and a number of people have
already pointed this out we can simply
have an optional command where enemy
character models get switched back to
their defaults that way you and your
team can still benefit from all the cool
character models you've unlocked but it
won't negatively affect your competitive
play making a client-side command as a
leisure and war owl and others have
already suggested and call it a day I
expect valve to implement something like
this very soon so if you're suffering if
you're one of the people getting one
tapped from the shadows like your
enemies Harry Potter wearing the [ __ ]
invisibility cloak don't worry I think
help is on the way
Wow let's see them put it on my ponies
don't now with that out of the way this
Update delivered so much content I mean
just the skins alone are beautiful
they're some of the best cases I've ever
seen especially the shattered web case
in particular also good news for all you
sick weirdos who use Galil x' and for my
FAMAS boys because both guns have been
buffed in the form of price decreases
and increased accuracy and spraying at
the same time the Krieg has been made
more expensive again ending months and
months and months of very annoying
dominance except for me because I'm bad
and I used it
nice in all seriousness though it is
interesting to see valve continue this
trend of forcing more gun diversity on
the community is it a good thing maybe
you don't see a lot of pros liking it
but that's totally understandable when
your job is to play CS when that puts
food on your plate you want to
concentrate on playing the nuances of
the game improving your tactics your
team play but little things you don't
want to have to go back to a gun you've
never clicked on in your life and learn
how to use it suddenly because valve
decided it's now meta at the same time
disruption can be a pretty fun thing
from a spectators point of view it can
allow certain players and certain teams
who become early adopters of new metas
to succeed although let's be honest it's
gonna take a stroll it's like five
minutes to figure out how to use the
FAMAS in a broken way have confidence
and go together to clear a date declare
it but in doing so they leave themselves
open to the Vice take back everything I
said he could have pulled around Oscar
gets one but he's now the last alive and
the shotgun into freeze hands he knows
exactly where he is it's the aux aive
that's so sick regarding the new
operation coop missions or single-player
challenges while I insta bot shattered
Webb after my vacation might haven't got
a chance to try them yet so I'm sure
they're great same with the maps and hey
how about those pearlescent skins being
pearlescent means a weapons color will
deviate from how it was originally
moving across the color spectrum how
much they do this by depends on the
angle they're viewed from and from how
big their pearlescent value is which is
hidden somewhere inside CS ghost files
right well anyways all in all I think
this update is in a word disruptive and
disruptive in my books is a good thing
at least in moderation
yes I'm very somber about Star Wars I
think the new trilogy is very bad I
think the last video is video yeah I
think well going is good I don't think
it's a masterpiece I think it's good
yeah that's crazy horse force awakens is
fine